it's time for roses and Rose a I'm
disgusting the heater is not you guys I
have not washed my hair in a week I have
to tell the truth to you because you're
my people this is my priority and that's
why skip showering to come drink wine
and watch that's right
the men are meeting Rachel family Peter
fryers are not in that order
Erik was second the Lindsay's I love the
Lindsay's I love them
let's say just a little family let's
dive in Peter you're going first so
Peter goes first
and he knows baby clothing sizes
she's a big threes right where I know
yeah
you guys split up as a drink every time
Peter did something else to make you
fall for him I know that you're
introducing a good person that's here
for you
but be very careful it's a dangerous
game so rachel is going to have the guys
all meet her family in Dallas because
her sister Constance who is amazing
we'll get to that is super duper
pregnant and I guess she can't travel I
don't know I don't have kids she can't
travel I guess so
because the baby can't be on a plane
nobody likes the baby on the plane
anyway so Rachel's like Peter let's go
pick up some clothes from your baby and
Peter knows baby clothing sizes pick get
ready for Peter I don't think I've ever
felt this passionately about a
contestant if you guys have felt more
passionately about a contestant please
leave in the comments below I'd like to
know I'd like to know all right so
what's also great about the guys being
all together is that when one guy goes
from you Rachel's family and the other
guys talk about him he sets the bar
really low just kind of amazing said he
may not even ask for her hand in
marriage like even even if she picks him
I think seemingly a producer told Brian
that Peter said that he might not
propose to Rachel
even if she picks him cuz Brian knew an
aerosol like wow what I know and that's
foreshadowing for all the crap that goes
down I am falling in love I'm so happy
to hear you say that the producer maybe
also seemingly told Peter that he should
probably tell Rachel he's falling for
her because he's gotta sing something
she wasn't to play around she says
they're really compatible but he's going
to show something so Peters like I'm
falling in love with you
well now we're like we're gonna fall
into the arms of a Lindsay is our future
family
okay and my uncle Jack bummer
we are not gonna meet Rachel's dad gotta
be a federal judge okay so my my parents
met in the walking
and whoa whoa whoa mom she'll all right
that was the lamest sauce oh look I'm on
my dropping her anyway Peter says that
his parents dated for one month a month
very quick Oh
one month before his death suppose and
they've been married for 32 I came into
this very skeptical and unsure that it
could actually happen
okay so Peter why are you so afraid to
propose after a couple weeks
your parents Dana works out welcome them
I'm confused I'm confused and you know
what it just makes me think Peter it
looks like are we watching The
Bachelorette anymore or are we watching
a prequel to Peter Krause the season of
The Bachelor it's like I'm so perfect
and I got I got a wall I gotta climb
over and all you women around the world
sign up for casting calls and help me
climb it as you voraciously climb over
it yourselves like animals because
that's how we all feel
okay so Constance is going to speak for
us all this whole episode Constance is
like pcs relaxed and you know very
handsome yes he does Constance
you know what's up with your belt
sleeves or staple necklaces mm-hmm I
love constant she's the one come
okay so Peter goes to RIT now the thing
about visiting the family is it's always
like are you going to ask for the hand
in marriage I want to wait until I know
for certain that your daughter is the
person for me
which I like he goes to Rachel's mom and
he's like I want to ask for your
blessing to keep spinning her because I
guess it's like you know courtship
I think we're here for a courtship boy
but Rachel's mom is like I love it which
I like and basically Rachel's whole
family loves Peter and her cousin is
like scissors winner okay
so drink as you know nothing wrong with
Peter Meechum a pleasure okay so Peters
date is done and side note Peter pretty
much hates Bryce I'm not the biggest fan
of life and if you love Peter that might
be a telling side note for you Dean was
here and shaylen mom told me in our
interview that Peter and I never really
got along and oh my god dwell forward
ready bar I'm ready baby
all right let's go Erik is I always
wonder about the order what does it mean
is she most excited for family and news
he knows she's dating Brian best for
last
are these even airing in the order of
the Ural filmed unclear but Erik is next
for us the viewer you've done this
before
twice Johnny
I've met two girls families and one of
them was a prom at prom Eric that's not
teaching is not going home meets on the
family picking them up for prom and
Rachel states that involved family is
important to me you know and it's like
that's what I really want for myself is
family Eric who's gonna redeem himself
and that is Eric's story on this show
they starts off kind of sketchy and then
he redeemed himself and he loved them so
much maybe Eric for bachelor I don't
hate it
I don't hate it he's got a story - okay
Peter though right yeah so the big issue
with Eric is you know he's never been in
love but Eric is so good at explaining
the roots of its story and as I
challenged them to have never thought
about and I love Eric thank you
commitment we're all cylinders and also
Eric might not have never been in love
Amanda's you know how to explain love
that's all these advocates um
compromises communication Oh sacrifice
understand him Eric Eric yeah I think
you explained to better than anybody
really so Eric asked for the blessing
for marriage proposal you daughter take
her hand in marriage
and Rachel's mom says something so
brilliant at this point I'm okay with it
because I trust Rachel which is a very
smart way for a very smart family to get
around the kind of weird situation that
they're in
for this show these girls are truly my
friends and I think they will be very
crucial to the date because they get me
Oh Brian and Brian is going to meet
Rachel Stein interesting if Bryan
meeting Rachel's friends because
Rachel's most excited about him or
because Rachel wants her friends to read
him we were just going over the really
embarrassing questions we want to ask
yeah because he's the only one who did
it
37
okay night also side note why is it that
when we meet new people and they tell us
things about themselves they're always
like oh nice
like oh I work as a janitor at a jail
and I'm constantly beaten by the
prisoners oh nice
how do we do that we do final norm okay
I've probably had too much of this and
it's so hot aside okay
so Rachel admits that she thought Bryan
was a closed douchebag at first
douchebag honestly I mean another reason
to love Rachel and she said in our
interview she was glad that she didn't
like Bryan at first and so we should all
give him a chance because she did give
him a chance so think about that
everybody
I liked Bryan on this episode I think he
was really nervous meeting her family
and that he was really not saying
anything bad it's just that there's
anything too much of what he was saying
and that comes across as as the men of
the season has said it's disingenuous
not a word guy okay so Bryan meets the
friends and Rachel is like you guys I
know he's not fake I do not have time to
fake it I have a tremendous amount of
love for this woman right next to me
Rachel brother-in-law what a bold bold
guy was the way he looked and didn't say
very much but just kind of staring and
Constance is back with another belt
sleeve in statement necklace
cheers to Constance I love her she's got
a lot to say about Bryan though I love
your family already I mean you guys seem
like a sea that's to say all of that so
soon to me like it's only been like an
hour yeah I'm yeah so even Rachel admits
that the energy is totally different men
and was the other two days with Peter
and Erin I'm like really low-key
boy but again you know Rachel's mom like
ask them the same questions wise and I
think he was nervous and they all seemed
really critical but then in the end the
moms like I trust you you beam on it I
think Brian appears very honest okay so
he has permission to those Rachel -
everybody does we're back to Spain how
do we know cobblestone streets old
cobblestone streets it's the marker of
Europe throughout this season Wow we're
gonna so eric is so excited for a
helicopter I don't know why because
haven't we seen enough helicopters at
this point of season but here's another
thing I love about Eric he is just happy
to be wherever he is he's like we're
here we are here yeah we're here hear me
where are we
we're here we out here we are here yeah
here we are
I'm here where are you I'm here and I
love it
get over here don't you want to spend
your life with somebody you're just
happy to be here they're not gonna
change my mind about Peter four
bachelors just
Eric and Rachel I've dinner and they
have some sod for no reason and Rachel
is so good at like kind of knowing what
needs to happen on this show and she's
on your drive and how you feel
and Eric's like a little oh I love you
[Music]
great wonderful because now we're going
to favorite be sweet we wake up the next
morning in the beds unmade and Eric's
shirtless and it's not a lot of facts
put it into a lot of implications so one
more shameless plug it's a trio in honor
of the three remaining guys tonight I
talked to Rachel about fantasy suites
and who she slept with and who she
didn't in what she said off camera it's
all over TV online calm don't drink
every time I make a shameless plug why
have my voice changed when I when I chug
that I don't know like a fun party trick
so I never meant to help okay and then
Peter Peter dances his way into this
vineyard in Spain drink again another
reason love here he's a good dancer I
mean I can't
yeah running out of road babe he can
read me and understand me more than any
other person here on this journey and
that brings a smile to my face
Rachel said the Peter understands her
better than anyone on mixtures better
than anyone who does she love him too
she went to pick I don't think that one
is good hold on so they go to a vineyard
and they manage to on this season of The
Bachelor I'd find yet another old person
who's been married for a long time in
Europe great
and he gives Rachel and Peter the key to
their own little wine cellar I want them
all rock hell if he drove and got
another reason left here what's his
priority the wine mm-hmm I can't he's
literally like can we take all the wine
are we just leaving with all this gray
something I don't know that what I want
them all god I love him we cut the later
so I favorite cork from a bottle of wine
Peter for the win and Peter's like I
didn't have this tradition my family
where I save this fork for a memory and
Rachel's like Peter for the win for the
win your family said he was a winner for
the win and then things take a dark dark
dark turn you guys they have to address
the fact that Peter did not ask Rachel's
parents for her hand in marriage and
Rachel explained what she thinks
engagement is I feel like it's
cultivating a relationship and seeing
what you have and if you can work
outside of that and then Peter explains
what he thinks engagement is engagement
just like we're getting married
let's just play in the time now
and they are not the same and then if
you drink every time they say I don't
know in this awkward space of time you
will not even know who you are I don't
want to get to that I don't either
I'll have the answers for you I don't
know where to go from there to be honest
neither
[Music]
I don't know what to tell you I mean
have the ice cubes at a strike huh again
I'd go stance they're saying they don't
know Rachel in devastated this is the
first time machine question of her and
Peter can make it neither of them knows
what to say and then we cut food and
Peter Krause is quiet he is crying there
are tears pouring from his beautiful
face why why why well we've gotta wait
two weeks to find out because the men
tell all airs next week and then we're
going to get the finale and then we're
going to find out why Peters crying but
but but I've once even grace for you
guys
I talked to Rachel about why Peter is
crying and that interview is uppity
token calm and I don't have any Rosa
left for this last shameless plug but
this last shameless plug represents
uncertainty as some heed forth into the
Bachelorette finale airing August 7th on
ABC god I love this show make sure to
LIKE you can't Facebook subscribe to us
on YouTube you can connect with me about
the Bachelorette over on Twitter
Instagram and snapchat I have a great
night everybody
don't cry me Peter cause the truth is
but we all love you whether you're the
bachelor or you just stand up in real
life we want to hold you make us
[Music]
it's getting weird I'm out okay bye
[Music]
and Eric is so excited to see Wow I just
it's my hair has gone downhill
throughout this taping it's trying to
fix it just like we got to try to fix
this relationship with Brian because
she's probably going to pick him so
we've got a resurrect okay okay not
great but okay
the motto of peace relationship